peas beans and clover are among the 18
000 species in the pea family
most species in this family including
these three are known as nitrogen fixers
they increase the level of nitrogen in
the soil which plants need to produce
proteins so they can grow
and chlorophyll so they can
photosynthesize one way to use this in
the garden is to interplant nitrogen
fixers with other plants that need a lot
of nitrogen
or you could plant a nitrogen-fixing
cover crop like clover for fertile soil
next year
okay this can be useful but doesn't
nitrogen fertilizer do the same thing
but more conveniently
why bother with this nitrogen fixation
thing
understanding this requires us to
understand how nitrogen fixation works
which in turn requires us to understand
the broader nitrogen cycle
so let's start with the big picture
nitrogen makes up 78 of the earth's
atmosphere by volume
but most of this nitrogen takes the form
of two nitrogen atoms strongly bonded
together
which isn't very reactive and is useless
to plants
for it to become plant available we need
the help of bacteria
various species of bacteria eat
atmospheric nitrogen and poop out
ammonium
this gets eaten by other kinds of
bacteria which poop out nitrite
which gets eaten by yet another kind of
bacteria which poops out nitrate
all of these forms of nitrogen are
available for plants especially nitrate
which is the easiest for plants to use
plants can take this up directly if it
is near their roots but they most often
rely on strands of fungi that attach to
their roots and bring nutrients to them
in exchange for the sugars and
carbohydrates the plant roots exude
dead plant material is also rich in
nitrogen and gets brought down with the
help of worms whose poop is a delicacy
among nitrifying bacteria
some of the ways nitrogen exits the soil
is when the crop is harvested
when water carries it away or when it
becomes gaseous and returns to the
atmosphere
or if the soil lacks oxygen different
anaerobic bacteria grow which convert
nitrates back into atmospheric nitrogen
notice that these things only happen
with loose nitrogen in the soil
not with nitrogen inside organisms
okay so we know that the nitrogen cycle
depends heavily on life in the soil
without them the plants would be quite
sad but you may have noticed
if the fixation process is done by
bacteria where do nitrogen-fixing plants
fit into this
believe it or not nitrogen-fixing plants
don't fix nitrogen
rather they create habitat for the
bacteria that do the roots of this
clover plant have little nodules that
house huge amounts of nitrogen-fixing
bacteria
the ammonium that these bacteria create
slowly releases into the soil for
neighboring plants and microorganisms to
use
when the plant dies the bacteria
disperse into the soil
resulting in an abundance of bacterial
allies for future plants nitrogen needs
you know how earlier i said that water
can carry soil nitrogen away
this nitrogen ends up in rivers which
can disrupt the ecosystem by enabling
algae to dominate
but remember this only happens to lose
nitrogen in the soil
and not nitrogen embedded in organisms
and fertilizer
adds pure nitrogen without the organisms
so when it rains
huge amounts of it runoff and pollute
the water loose nitrogen
molecules are also much more prone to
volatilization releasing huge amounts of
nitrous oxide a potent greenhouse gas
into the atmosphere but that's not all
such quantities of pure nitrogen
irritate earthworms which end up dying
or leaving
it disrupts the helpful fungus on plant
roots and changes the soil ph
making it inhospitable to bacteria in
short it kills the soil
when the nitrogen all gets used up or
washes away the organisms aren't there
to help the plants get more so now you
have to add more fertilizer which
worsens the problem
and these organisms did much more than
just supply nitrogen the root fungi also
brought up important minerals for the
plants
and now that they're gone mineral
fertilizer must also be used
instead of working with this
self-sustaining web of organisms freely
sharing nutrients
we have to spend more money to add loads
of fertilizer to dead soil
poisoning the water and contributing to
climate change considering the inability
of dead soil to supply plants with
nutrients
it's no wonder that throughout the last
century vegetables have been steadily
declining in nutritional value
healthy food requires healthy soil
so if the soil around you is rich and
alive try to keep it that way
but if like most of us the soil around
you is dead or dying
nitrogen fixers can help to add a little
more life so that someday our tiny
allies under our feet will come back
you